una sera sapete cosa significa
questa non c'era
e non è un caso perché questo una parola
può essere chiave inserite non vi aver
minato contesto e quasi non esistere un
altro
pensate alla pari al concetto di neve ci
sono 99 termini per essere identificata
questa parola inneschi mese ce ne sono
circa 15 in svedese c'è soltanto uno in
italiano neve invece l'ora this raptiva
è molto molto attuale negli stati uniti
d'america dove negli ultimi 12 mesi è
stata cercata più di un milione di volte
su google
l'italia nemmeno dieci volte e bella
prova ovvero raccontare il significato
di questa di questo termine con una
slide nel fare nuove cose ci sono due
modi di fare cioè l'innovazione che vuol
dire fare che faresti vuol dire fare le
stesse cose un pochino meglio
e poi c'è la disruption ovvero fare le
cose nel modo tale in cui come le si
facevano prima risulti obsolete e allora
per fare un esempio un pochino più
concreto c'è una citazione bellissima di
henry ford in cui che lui si chiedeva in
cui se avessi chiesto ai miei clienti
cosa volevano mi avrebbero risposto un
cavallo più veloce il cavallo più veloce
era sicuramente innovativo la
l'automobile
quindi la carrozza senza cavalli davanti
era di serrati ma è allora quello che
ricorda all'inizio della della sua
impresa e considerava l'automobile era
pura magia lo faccio con un esempio
ancora più concreto magari più
contemporaneo e quello del telefono se
se avete in mente il nokia 33 10 che
tutti abbiamo avuto era sicuramente più
innovativo rispetto al 32 10 era piu
leggero era più nuovo ma non era non è
non era mothes ratti versato l'iphone
nel primo iphone già dal 2008 da steve
jobs e allora e prova a raccontare
perché questo questa this rapide stata
così importante dei miei ultimi 10 anni
erano io dal partendo allo status quo
avevo 21 anni era new york nel
bellissimo ufficio alle imprese billing
41 esimo piano e facevo e fa insistito
di commercialisti quindi iniziamo a
lavorare con lo stipendio molto alto ci
avevo in italia un'attività familiare
già avviata e quindi stata una
situazione abbastanza ideale solo che
qualcosa non funzionava quella era il
mio desk non mi divertivo così tanto a
registrare fatture e a vedere i bilanci
degli altri e allora quello che mi
aspettavo dalla le aspettative che avevo
all'università di andare a lavorare e
come commercialista cominciavano ad
annoiarmi e allora in quegli stessi anni
così passavo le mie giornate
professionali in quegli stessi anni se
invece volevo andare in vacanza a fare
un weekend lunga chicago quella era una
stanza d'hotel 12 metri quadri asettica
impersonale se invece volevo andare a
cena fuori
dovevo scendere prestata alzarla mano
aspettare un taxi e poi una volta salito
controllare il tassametro e controllare
il tassista e se invece si voleva vedere
un film
una sera a casa bisogna comunque uscire
di casa o andare alla blockbuster vedere
devo andare a scegliere un titolo un
film basato sul titolo su una copertina
per poi tornare a casa e rischiare che
neanche il film che avete scelto neanche
ti piacesse
e allora qualcosa doveva cambiare in
quell'anno io devo pensare a cambiare
nella mia vita professionale avevo avevo
la sensazione di mettere il cervello
quando arrivava in ufficio a mettere nel
cassetto per poi riprenderlo alle sedi
pomeriggio e allora il quel cervello
hanno abusato e allora è così che
cominci si passa al momento è quel
momento mi il mio momento messaggio nel
2013 tre anni più tardi dove da una
stanza dove da in quel palazzo nel west
village
ho avuto un incontro casuale fortunato
ho cominciato con una stanza ad
affittarla all'inizio di airbnb e quindi
tutto quello che era il l'incubo di ogni
persona che arrivava a new york a
cercare un alloggio io affittavo queste
queste stanze la fitta vo creando un
arbitraggio tra gli affitti che pagavo a
lungo termine a quel signore e gli
affitti che incassavo a breve termine da
dagli italiani e allora
nella slide per il dopo negli stessi
anni così come io pensavo a cambiare la
mia vita professionale ea migliorarmi
conti in banca ci stavano qualcun'altro
qualche altro coetaneo che che pensava
invece a cambiare a rivoluzionare a
reinventare i propri settori e quindi
airbnb è huber cioè non c'è bisogno che
spiego questa slide in quanto tutti noi
traiamo benefici da da queste società
e allora questo momento ma è il è quel
momento e quell'episodio quella scelta
che sembra apparentemente banale ma che
poi scatena un effetto domino e allora
vediamo come si passa da questo status
quo che tutti abbiamo al momento ci sono
tre filosofie e tre consigli che vorrei
darvi la prima la filosofia della fine
quindi iniziare dalla fine ovvero avere
in mente avere in testa qual è
l'obiettivo finale
cosa si vuole raggiungere è soltanto
avendo chiaro qual è l'obiettivo allora
verranno sarà tutto più facile
si daranno le giuste priorità ed è
quello che io ho fatto proiettandomi più
la revoca pt mangiando che non voglio
fare il commercialista ed è quello che
che consiglio nel senso che la la siamo
il loro posto potrebbe essere siamo
tutti intrappolati in attività sbagliate
ovvero saliamo una scala appoggiata sul
muro sbagliato e quindi ogni passo ogni
scalino che si farà verso l'altro
faticosamente non far altro che portarvi
più velocemente in una meta in un
successo che non è il nostro
e allora il consiglio la giusta arco
temporale è di tre anni
perché
se guardi troppo in là vent'anni c'è il
rischio di sbagliare se guardi a due
mesi non serve a nulla e così quando si
guida l'auto non bisogna guardare a 50
centimetri al cruscotto perché si
rischia di fare l'incidente non bisogna
nemmeno guardare a a cinque chilometri
questa c'è una seconda filosofia che è
la filosofia del limite anche ve la
racconto meglio con una storiella irish
ci sta un imprenditore che di calzature
che in sede di bilancio guarda al fano
riunione vede che ci sono rimanenze di
scarpe un imprenditore di calzature
allora prende il primo figlio daniele
dice danni e prendi tutte le scarpe
valle a vendere in quell'isola d'aria e
prende tutte arriva nell'isola si guarda
intorno tutti scalzi chiama il padre di
due mi ha mandato qui sono tutti scalzi
e rientra allora il papa prende il
secondo figlio di david by tu prendi le
scarpe vanno a vendere l'isola la ville
prende tutte le scarpe arriva nell'isola
si guarda intorno tutti scalzi chiama il
pareggio qua 10.000 scarpe non bassa
domanda rinforzi che che che qui sono
tutti scalzi questo è quello che
dobbiamo fare dove c'è un limite c'è
dietro l'opportunità e così come in
quella sede si vedeva che davanti
all'ostacolo davanti al muro o bisogna
soltanto fare un cambio di prospettiva
bisogna quindi bisogna avere la
combinazione di essere fortunati
abbastanza da essere esposti al limite e
avere quell'atteggiamento atteggiamento
mentale quella bravura di vedere quello
stesso limite come opportunità
e poi c'è una terza filosofia che è
quella della scelta che la racconta
invece con una parabola di un animale
l'animale l'aragosta che probabilmente
nessuno si è mai chiesto come fa
un'aragosta crescere e la ragazza che è
un animale e soffice e molle rinchiuso
da un guscio rigido fa sì che proprio
quel guscio che la limita che la soffoca
la ragosta per scendere si mette sotto
una roccia per difendersi rompe quel
guscio per produrne uno nuovo e questo
continuo passaggio di rottura per poter
crescere far sì che la ragosta cresce
quindi c'è un disagio nasce tutto da un
disagio da un senso di oppressione che
fa sì che dalla spinta per poter
liberarsi di questa corazza e questo è
quello che dobbiamo fare ognuno di noi
ha una corazza intorno a un armi un
abito troppo troppo corto
un uno schema che gli è stato un
percorso scelto agli altri bisogna avere
la forza di uscire dal proprio comfort
zone di poter liberarsi di quegli schemi
e di poter scegliere il proprio percorso
soltanto così si avrà una vita appagante
una
si fa si andrà incontro a un percorso
che si è scelto e quindi se avrà la
forza di poter superare quegli ostacoli
abbiamo visto cos'è di tratti facciamo
status quo e si passa al momento ma e
questo è fondamentale ma c'è una cosa
che è ancora più importante questo
continuo passaggio e una vita realmente
disruptive è una vita che che fa sì che
questo passaggio è continua
ogni status quo va trasformato in
momento attraverso bravura attraverso
queste filosofie e quel momento però
inevitabilmente tornerà a essere status
quo e quello e quindi questo continuo
passaggio fa sì che si fa una vita di
drafting lo fanno i grandi imprenditori
lo fanno grandi aziende lo fa huber per
esempio che si è quotata settimana
scorsa a wall street e con una
capitalizzazione di 70 miliardi ma che
dalla forza che aveva ovvero di render
conducenti ognuno di noi che arrotondava
lo stipendio facendomi dando le proprie
macchine oggi investe miliardi nella
tecnologia del self driving lo faccio io
che sono tornato ho provato a far vivere
sono tornato dall'america a vivere in
italia con provando con l'ambizione con
la missione di di costruire il futuro
dell'hospitality sono il gruppo sanders
questo appartamento di roma e quindi
questa vi lascio con un proverbio cinese
in cui quando soffia il vento del
cambiamento alcuni costruiscono muri
altri mulini a vento
qui abbiamo capito come si passa da
status quo a momentum l'importanza e
continuare a fare e dovete farlo e
vedere che quel vento che dovete usare
quel vento come l'elemento mancante per
poter far girare le vostre pare far
funzionare i vostri mulini e non vederlo
come un elemento distruttivo
grazie a tutti voi laterale
[Applauso]